-We are joined right now
by an incredible young magician
who was just named
the first winner
of "America's Got Talent:
The Champions."
Give it up for Shin Lim.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Now, you see those dice in your
hand. You want to examine them?
Just make sure that all
the sides are different.
-You just placed this
in my hand.
-Yeah, right. You can roll it up
and throw it into the cup.
-Okay.
-Just try to make it random.
Go ahead. Take a look at top.
Do you see those two numbers?
Add it up.
What does it add up to?
-Do you want me to tell you?
-Yeah, yeah, doesn't matter.
-10.
-I can know. 10. Cool.
So we have the number 10.
And then let's get, um --
Let's see. Tariq.
Do you have a suit in mind?
Clubs, hearts, diamonds, spades.
Just name any one.
-I'm gonna say hearts.
-Hearts? All right, cool.
So, 10, hearts.
Completely random selection.
I have a deck of cards here.
♪♪♪♪
Watch.
The entire deck
turns into the 10.
-Oh, my God.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait. Jimmy, don't move.
Okay? Don't move.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay, look. Don't move. Okay?
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Dude, I don't know
how you're doing this.
Oh, my God.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪♪♪
-You guys should, uh,
check out your inside pockets.
Yeah, go ahead. Everyone.
Check out your inside pockets.
You might feel something.
-Wait!
-No!
-Aah! Aah!
-Yeah! Ha, ha!
-Wait.
Watch.
♪♪♪♪
Oh, no, no. Just watch.
-Whoa! Yo!
What is going on?!
Oh, my gosh!
♪♪♪♪
Dude is insane.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Watch the floor.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
This is unbelievable.
How in the world?
-Thank you very much, everybody.
-How in the world?
Dude, what is going on?!
You are amazing.
You are awesome.
Shin Lim, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
Awesome!